throughout its 12-season run the big
bang theory remained a ratings and
cultural juggernaut but just because
something is popular does not
automatically mean it is perfect here
are some questionable things we ignore
in the big bang theory
fans who only started watching the big
bang theory after howard married
bernadette might not realize how big of
a creep howard was before settling down
with the love of his life in the
earliest seasons howard was basically a
predator and penny was often the
unfortunate recipient of his unwanted
attentions one of the most unsettling
throwaway jokes from early on in the
show was when howard asked penny if she
would have opened the door if she knew
he was standing outside to this penny
replies not since i found out the teddy
bear you gave me had a webcam in it
[Applause]
this was not even the only time howard
tried to use technology to spy on an
attractive woman without her consent he
and raj went to great lengths to figure
out the location of the house from
america's next top model where all the
models were staying even making illegal
use of a government satellite in the
process howard's antics are always
played for laughs but it is clear that
his behavior rubs every woman he meets
the wrong way this was confirmed when he
tried to kiss penny and she punched him
in the eye in retaliation the truth is
if the show was even slightly realistic
a lot of the stunts howard pulled to try
to get with women could have landed him
in jail
the big bang theory was a show that
thrived on making jokes about
stereotypes as the show's rare main
character who's also non-white raj was
often the subject of mockery based on
his indian heritage over the years many
jokes were made about raj coming from a
country that is poor and overpopulated
where animals are considered magic and
where the culture and religion were
silly
that's very offensive
after a time the show eased up on the
indian joke somewhat but the attacks
against raj became more personal every
aspect of the character's life from his
lack of a romantic partner to personal
interests and physical appearance were
constantly made fun of worse it was
usually raja's best friend howard making
those jokes to the extent that the two
had a brief falling out because raj did
not like the way howard constantly
bullied him the end of the show did
nothing to give raj any sort of a
redemption arc he remained the only main
character to not have a special someone
when the series ended due to facing one
bitter disappointment in his love life
after another he was also shown to have
become much more dependent on his
parents for financial support and
essentially replaced sheldon as the
man-child unable to function as a mature
adult
before jim parsons made sheldon the star
of the show the big bang theory was
mainly about leonard trying to
desperately date penny in time after
many false stops and starts leonard and
penny finally became a couple when they
tie the knot and move in together but
that was far from the happily ever after
scenario that fans had been expecting
soon after their marriage fans started
noticing that penny was becoming more
than a little mean towards leonard she
belittled his accomplishments made fun
of his relationship with his mother and
frequently made fun of him in group
settings when penny and raj were
discussing how howard constantly makes
mean-spirited comments about raj he
points out that penny does the same
thing with leonard she agrees with that
assessment but perhaps the biggest sign
that all was not well in penny and
leonard's marriage due to penny's
attitude occurs in the episode the
romance recalibration at first penny
thinks leonard has stopped trying in
their relationship since getting married
but then leonard points out the opposite
i'm the one who's made all the effort in
this relationship since day one please
tell me what more i could do
later seasons of the big bang theory
gave us strong female characters and
story lines thanks to the addition of
amy and bernadette to the main cast but
this only serves to highlight how the
early seasons of the show were only
interested in presenting women as the
mysterious other almost like they were
aliens the central premise upon which
the show itself was built had to do with
the awkwardness of the main four male
characters in social situations
particularly pertaining to women howard
acts like a thirsty creep around females
raj is literally unable to even speak to
them without getting drunk sheldon has
no interest in interacting with them and
leonard perhaps the most normal of the
group can't even ask out penny or any
other attractive woman due to a
crippling inferiority complex because of
this setup females on the show were all
too often presented as one-dimensional
characters whose only contribution to
the plot was being hot or whether or not
the male characters had a chance of
sleeping with them this trend was summed
up perfectly in the episode the justice
league recombination when sheldon
questions whether penny's wonder woman
outfit is authentic enough without a
black wig howard dismisses his concerns
with the remark
relax no one's going to be looking at
her hair
in a sea of awkward anti-social geeks
the big bang theory initially presented
penny as the sole voice of reason the
street smart kind-hearted simpleton did
not mind being friends with geeks and
even helped them open up to the rest of
the world this however is far from the
reality of penny's relationship with the
guys penny is shown to be clearly aware
of the effect her looks have on leonard
raj and howard and she often uses it to
her advantage she eats food that the
guys order without paying her share she
steals their wi-fi and uses their brains
whenever she needs something technical
done even worse she made leonard go to
her ex-boyfriend's house to pick up her
things after only knowing him for a few
days leading to leonard getting bullied
by her ex both him and sheldon get their
pants taken
leonard
what my mom bought me those pants i'm
sorry
it is also shown that penny is aware of
her manipulative behavior since she
grows insecure when a new pretty girl
moves into their building and proceeds
to use the guys in exactly the same
manner as her the big bang theory is
often held up as an example of a show
that brought the geek way of life into
the cultural mainstream while it is true
that the show is chock full of
references to the most obscure facets of
geek culture how it explores those
facets is more than a little
questionable oftentimes the entire
punchline of a joke is that these grown
men are actually interested in something
so geeky consider the following actual
joke from an actual episode on the show
the fate of doctor who's tardis will be
decided by a game of thrones inspired
death match on the battlefield of
thundercats vs transformers
that's it that's the entire joke just a
bunch of references to various sci-fi
and fantasy franchises many times the
show doesn't set up a reference to an
aspect of geek culture using that
reference to create actual humor instead
all too often the entire joke is showing
how obsessed these man children are with
something that's somehow meant for kids
in the hands of a lesser actor sheldon
would have become the most insufferable
character in the history of television
it is a testament to jim parson's skill
as an actor that he managed to make
audiences fall in love with sheldon
instead of viewing the character as the
awful awful person he really is from the
start of the show sheldon has proven
himself time and again to be petty
selfish vindictive controlling and
callous he constantly makes fun of his
friends for not being as smart as him he
has made several jokes at the expense of
women your ovaries are squirting so much
goofy juice into your brains you don't
even know which way is up
he even showed his assistant alex
graphic images of human genitals without
her consent some of this behavior wound
up getting him sexual harassment
accusations at work whenever sheldon
acts like a complete tool the show makes
it clear that he does so out of
ignorance rather than active malice that
excuse would only work if sheldon
himself did not take offense when others
act inappropriately towards him but in
those cases sheldon is always very quick
to take offense clearly sheldon has a
working understanding of right and wrong
but his dismissive attitude towards the
entire human race including his closest
friends and family makes him indifferent
to any hurt he might cause to others
that is until he is specifically called
out on his behavior
over time leonard became one of the most
pathetic fictional characters ever
created in the beginning he was shown to
allow sheldon to walk all over him in
terms of their living arrangements after
marriage penny replaced sheldon as the
person who constantly orders leonard
around and then to cap it all off we
meet leonard's mother beverly it would
be hard to overstate just how much
emotional abuse beverly subjected
leonard to from a young age she withheld
affection turned a critical gaze on
everything leonard tried to do and acted
dismissive towards his achievements to
top it all off leonard discovers that
his mother subjected him to a number of
psychological experiments from an early
age and published the findings for the
world to see
every time i'm around her i turn into
this needy little eight-year-old boy
all of this left deep scars on leonard's
psyche but in a case of adding insult to
injury beverly remains largely
indifferent to leonard's feelings she
often acts as though leonard is being
unduly emotional and that she had in
fact been a model mother even though
leonard and beverly eventually reach
some sort of an understanding the damage
done to leonard in terms of turning him
into a human doormat will probably never
be reversed
sheldon is openly acknowledged to be a
pretty terrible person because there's
very little artifice in him and he
doesn't try to hide his true nature but
sheldon has some tough competition in
the biggest douchebag department from
none other than sweet tiny bernadette
who was deceptively sneaky about being a
major bully a prime example of bernie's
hidden nature was seen way back when
everyone thought she was sweetness and
delight personified sheldon is trumped
by a physics problem and the rest of the
group are suffering the consequences
when they are all fed up bernie is the
one to stand up to sheldon she talks to
him like he's a child and sends him to
bed but the true extent of bernadette's
mean-spirited nature was realized once
her professional life came into focus it
comes to light that everyone at her
office is terrified of bernadette even
her boss in fact everyone working in the
same building as her collectively
decides to repurpose the handicapped
washroom as bernadette's private
lavatory after she keeps on using it
this bullying aspect of bernie's nature
frequently leaks into her private life
in episodes to come so much so that even
penny grows wary of accidentally making
bernadette angry
in general it is repeatedly emphasized
just how smart and capable the male
characters are when it comes to their
jobs particularly sheldon but just
because they have the brains to be good
at their jobs doesn't mean they have the
ethics to go along with it in fact
leonard sheldon raj and howard should be
in jail for some of the things they've
done while on the job for instance there
was the time when leonard almost
divulged state secrets to a north korean
spy to make her sleep with him or when
leonard raj and howard illegally tested
an experimental rocket fuel formula in a
public area and blew up their
residential building's elevator as a
result then there's the time when howard
crashed the mars rover space vehicle
while trying to impress a random girl he
met in a bar and let's not forget when
sheldon and leonard tried to illegally
procure liquid helium through a shady
contact honestly sometimes you have to
wonder how the guys have managed to stay
out of jail and hold on to their jobs
for so long
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]